IT'S NOW TIME FOR THE HASHTAG
WARS.
EARLIER TONIGHT THE COLLEGE
FOOTBALL SEASON CAME TO A
HEAD BASHING CLIMAX AS
OREGON TOOK ON OHIO STATE.
SO IN HONOR OF THE MASCOT BATTLE
OF DUCK VERSUS BUCKEYES,
I'M TOLD THAT'S A NUT OF SOME
KIND -- TONUGHT'S HASHTAG IS
#MoreAccurateMascots,
#MoreAccurateMascots.
FOR EXAMPLE, TONIGHT'S GAME
WOULD HAVE BEEN THE OREGON
CRUNCHY VEGAN VERSUS THE
OHIO STATE DYING RUST BELTS.
OR ALMA MATER, THE U.C.L.A.
FUTURE HOSTS OF SHIPMATES.
I'M GONNA PUT 60 SECONDS ON THE
CLOCK BEGIN.
JEN KIRKMAN.
>> THE UVA DATE RAPIST.
>> CHRIS: OKAY, POINTS. MARON.
>> THE UNIVERSITY OF PHOENIX
INTERNET SPAM.
>> CHRIS: POINTS.
JOHN HODGMAN.
>> THE BROWN UNIVERSITY
PRIVILEGE CHECKERS.
>> CHRIS: POINTS.
YES, JEN.
>> DUKE UNIVERSITY DATE RAPIST.
>> CHRIS: POINTS.
MARC.
>> THE PENN STATE YOU KNOW
WHATS.
>> CHRIS: POINTS. JEN.
>> THE UNIVERSITY OF
NEBRASKA DATE RAPIST.
>> CHRIS: OKAY.
POINTS.
JOHN.
>> THE BERKELEY BLOND
DREADLOCKS.
>> CHRIS: POINTS.
JEN.
>> THE HARVARD C STUDENTS WITH
RICH FATHERS.
>> CHRIS: POINTS.
MARC.
>> THE USC SPIELBERGS.
>> CHRIS: POINTS. HODGMAN.
>> THE UNIVERSITY OF SOUTH
CAROLINA DINOSAURS, WHICH
COEXISTED WITH MAN.
>> CHRIS: POINTS.
JEN.
>> THE UNIVERSITY OF FLORIDA
EVOLUTION-NEGATORS.
>> CHRIS: POINTS, SO GOOD.